our friend jeff darlington back here on
the show how are you jeff yeah oh hey
that tourist story was fantastic
oh yeah the one we just played on our
peacock with him at the super bowl
okay was that did everybody not hear
that no the radio network did not but
that's great that you um i know you're
on hold
i'm more than happy to talk about it the
two at the at the super bowl in south
florida
um back in 2019 2020 calendar year
saying that nick saban went up to him
after he won the national championship
with a throw that
dug them out of such a deep hole that he
put them in because he took such a
terrible sack he joked with saban um
at the time and um that's interesting
that he chose to do that but it's
you know two was feeling his oats that's
for sure you know it reminds me of uh
another story
about the other guy the the other sabin
which is bill belichick
i was at the uh the patriots uh after
party and julian edelman
and danny and dola are spraying
champagne all over each other
and julian edelman says where's bill
with the champagne bottle he's going to
spray
this is after he gets the mvp he's going
to spray bill belichick
and danny amendola stops him and says
you can't do that man and he goes
what's he going to do fire me and danny
amendola looks at him and says
yes
those guys don't joke around man
they don't i know and uh brian flores
comes from the belichick
coaching tree as we know so um
walk me through uh what happened in
dolphins
camp mandatory mini camp with their
quarterback that
kind of has to work out one would say
right now the way things look in miami
go forward jeff darlington
so yeah i think this this one requires a
lot of context and
and well beyond the headline that is
that is obvious which is
tuatanga valor throws five interceptions
during
mini can practice um so here's the deal
first of which
this is now i'm not going to completely
sugarcoat this thing he didn't look
great
he didn't look great before the
torrential rain um
even when he wasn't throwing
interceptions he didn't look great
um and and this is this is a guy who i
talking to people in the organization
including yesterday before practice
people kept saying he's different he
came back different
he looks better physically he seems
better mentally just seems more prepared
for what he's about to endure um after
practice
i talked to somebody who said look
here's the deal i i
i can tell you i heard it flores told
them before practice
like this is a p called a passing camp
he said this is a teaching camp
uh that this is the time to be
aggressive to make mistakes
i want you firing downfield i i want you
doing those things that maybe you
wouldn't do during games in the season
so um you know
it's somewhere down the middle here like
is it cause for concern it's a june mini
camp probably not
but for a guy that is coming under such
uh obvious wonder about what he's gonna
do in year two
we're gonna probably criticize and look
at everything he does
including a practice in which he throws
five picks so
fair is probably somewhere down the
middle so then let's let's let's put the
five picks aside for a moment and
and just um say that's the reason why
we're having this conversation now
on on june 16th right yeah that that but
but it's still a conversation that was
being had
while he and fitzpatrick um were
on the same roster last year and
fitzpatrick as
fitzpatrick usually does gets the gig
back
for a couple of quarters when
the dolphins needed to make the playoffs
and it was obvious that tua was
struggling
to try and get the dolphins to that spot
and
now comes the whole conversation um
about desean watson let's be flat out
straightforward about this that the
dolphins have the draft capital still
to go and get desean watson should he
prove to be a viable quarterback
so let's just use this now as the
backdrop and revisit what you said about
him
showing up differently in miami what
what do they mean what it what are you
hearing about that what a
what do dolphins front office if not
coaches tell you on that front what's
the deal there
look i mean i i think that they're
trying to be as supportive
as possible uh to uh and and what he can
do this season
and i also think that they they at this
point
when we talk about the sean watson they
have to be because let's be honest
to right now throwing six pit or five
picks in a mini camp practice
still isn't as bad as or as
curious as the future of deshaun watson
um we don't know enough about whether
and when he will be available
it is way too speculative like i try i
started to go down this same
sort of avenue in my own head yesterday
as i'm watching to throw these pics
about watson
and then i'm sitting there saying when
is watson going to be available
is he going to play at all this year and
i understand we want to be as fair as
possible to this process
but even if this process
is played out expeditiously what does
that even mean
so yes if tua goes into training camp
and struggles and deshaun watson's
picture is more clear i don't know how
the dolphins can't consider it
but there is a lot that has to happen in
the coming months
for that to go from a conversation
between us
and a reality for the miami dolphins so
then let's just uh stay here for a
second before we
revisit how two is shown up differently
what are you hearing on this
i mean he's what's going on
look i've heard everything from his
footwork is better to look he's not
worried about he's not having to do
you know this time last year he was
having a combined learning a playbook
with
rehabilitating a hip uh
so you know there's a lot of factors
that people seem to think
will make him better uh i also can't
ignore
despite maybe it being a little unfair
what you brought up about fitzpatrick
last year
and if we go back to that final game
that they lost in the playoffs
with that final game of the year when
fitzpatrick had coveted
and if fitzpatrick did not have kobe you
cannot convince me for a second that he
is not in that game in the second half
and what kind of conversation are we now
having
if that was the case if tua couldn't
finish out that game
and then also was struggling now i think
he deserves the patience that the
dolphins are giving him
but i do understand those who are
wondering if he is the answer
it'll play out it's going to play out in
front of us we're going to see it
um i i get both sides of it to be
completely clear jeff darlington here on
the rich eisen show i mean tua did admit
earlier this
this uh spring that he wasn't as well
versed in the playbook
as i guess he needed to be and i don't
know how he could have been rich
i would defend him there right you know
last year was weird man
with kobed with his hip like
i get that i i do understand
why maybe he he's his transparency in
that
you know i get that it gets a little bit
of attention but i kind of understand it
and maybe maybe you shouldn't admit it
but he is he is nothing if not
an honest and vulnerable human
this is so fascinating to me jeff
because of who he
was in college and the story that the
dolphins pretty much the minute he
looked off for safety
to beat georgia in the national
championship game
changed their entire process
to get him borrow throws 60 touchdowns
thus tua is available for them but so is
justin herbert who has a season
in which he had the same offseason right
jeff where
he didn't have this he didn't have uh
on-field workouts he didn't have any of
that and he's
told literally five minutes before a
game you're starting against patrick
mahomes
and winds up being rookie winds up being
rookie of the year and we're sitting
here wondering
why tua's um you know
uh uh talent level can't uh
overcome lack of playbook knowledge in
the same way that we saw herbert do it
this past year
and rich that's that's the i feel like
i've contradicted myself 10 times and
i'm not just trying to agree with you
by any means here but like that's the
weird thing about this like when you try
to just treat the tula situation
in a vacuum you can be patient you can
be understanding
but then when you start to bring in
these other factors whether it's to sean
watson's potential availability
whether it's the fact that they could
have had justin herbert and there's no
way
there's no way that even the arden two
of fans
the guys who are most supportive can't
in the back of their head be sitting
there still saying
me and herbert looks good i mean you
can't he's
he just he looks he's so clearly at this
point of franchise quarterback so
i i am equally fascinated um
by what feels now to be more
of an experiment than a conviction into
a
and uh and i will be down here for every
minute of it
jeff charlington here on the rich eisen
show uh fresh off of the
miami dolphins um going
through the motions it seems right now
how many interceptions did jacoby briset
throw
yesterday two of his own oh my gosh so
everybody's just winging it all over the
lot huh
i mean it was it was torrential i mean
like again i'm not
it was the rain was ridiculous
it was ridiculous it wasn't that la rain
let me tell you what race
okay so uh what can you tell me about
what you're hearing on the
aaron rodgers front what do you got for
me from what you're
uh you know what's funny i keep i keep
hearing that it's not about the contract
it's not about the money
um i keep hearing in my conversations
that is about the contract it's about
the money
you know and it's it maybe it's maybe
it's somewhere in between like
i i from what i understand like i could
i see him wanting
the type of security that not only
provides him
faith in this year but faith
that if he winds up with another team
because the packers decide to move on
that he will still be equally secure and
i think that's a complicated statement
but this is a complicated situation and
i'm not going to just call him a
complicated seller
because i think the packers also
probably need to do a better job
of managing this thing from the outside
as well when he wore that sweatshirt
yesterday i'm offended do you think
do you think he really is offended or
he's making fun of media members
wondering if he's offended i can't
i can't i i can't feel him out either
man the second i
i and i think that's his goal just to
throw chaos into the mix like he he's a
oh oh you know what i'll agree with mark
murphy aaron rodgers is a complicated
fella
i'm just not the ceo who's trying to
convince him to come
work for me so i feel a little bit more
okay saying it than maybe mark said
no that's what i was saying on monday
when this whole thing came up is you
know you've been through
all the collective bargaining agreement
labor wars that which is the ultimate
negotiation that anybody who covers the
nfl
certainly for the last 10 15 20 years
will recall
we we may not see any greater uh
negotiation
in the national football league than
that one any statement can send anybody
sideways anybody right and so and so you
know
um to say complicated fella that also
indicates to the
fan base who's the the jury in the court
of public opinion we're not the
complicated one
you know we'll we'll have him in he's
the complicated fella like that's the
way it comes across even though
mark murphy probably did not mean it
that way you know so
maybe he didn't mean it that way but
rich he did the same thing like a week
earlier in a q a on the packers website
where someone
wasn't even asking a question about
aaron rodgers i mean you go look it up
and and
mark murphy took it upon himself to
bring up aaron rodgers
and dividing the families yeah dividing
the fan base that comment
it wasn't even the question it wasn't
even a question it was a statement
to mark murphy and it had nothing to do
with aaron rodgers so
like as much as i want to say yeah maybe
he didn't mean to do it well guess what
his job is to mean
to say the right things not the wrong
thing how could james jones fix this
jeff i mean he's saying that he can get
in a room and with with everybody and
fix it i
i don't i wouldn't want to be the
mediator of that situation
like aaron rodgers a guy
has he's he's too smart he's gonna
ultimately do
what he wants to do i i don't see
mediation of any kind i think he's going
to decide what he wants
and what's best for him and he's going
to say this is what i need to come back
i don't know what that is or when that
is and he's going to make that decision
but and i by the way i'll say this rich
i think he does play for the packers
this year
it doesn't make legit it doesn't make
logistical sense for him to sit out
uh based on the money based on the
legacy based on all of these things
i understand he's a prideful person but
he is also
a person of self-interest and i think
that he ultimately
will see that playing this year even if
it's his last
is in his best self-interest jeff uh i
appreciate the time man let's uh let's
keep chatting
let's keep chatting you be well you take
care thanks brother you bet that's jeff
darlington i follow him on twitter you
should follow him too at jeff darlington
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here